so when you think about a child a close
friend or a romantic partner the word
love probably comes to mind and
instantly other emotions rush in joy and
hope
excitement trust insecurity and yes
sometimes sadness and disappointment
there might not be a word in the
dictionary that more of us are connected
to than love yet given its central
importance in our lives isn't it
interesting that we're never explicitly
taught how to love we build friendships
navigate early romantic relationships
get married and bring babies home from
the hospital with the expectation that
we'll figure it out but the truth is we
often harm and disrespect the ones we
love it can be subtle things like
guilting a friend into spending time
with you or sneaking a peek at your
partner's text or shaming a child for
their lack of effort at school 100
percent of us will be on the receiving
end of unhealthy relationship behaviors
and 100 percent of us will do unhealthy
things it's part of being human in its
worst form the harm we inflict on loved
ones shows up as abuse and violence and
relationship abuse is something that 1
in 3 women and 1 in 4 men will
experience in their lifetime now if
you're like most people when you hear
those stats you go oh no no no that
would never happen to me it's
instinctual to move away from the words
abuse and violence to think that they
happen to someone else somewhere else
but the truth is unhealthy relationships
and abuse are all around us we just call
them different things and ignore the
connection abuse sneaks up on us
disguised in unhealthy love I work for
an organization called one love started
by a family whose daughter Yardley was
killed by her ex-boyfriend this was a
tragedy no one saw coming but when they
looked back they realized the warning
signs were there just no one on
stood what they were seeing called crazy
or drama or too much drinking his ink
his actions weren't understood to be
what they really were which was clear
signs of danger her family realized that
if anyone had been educated about these
signs her death could have been
prevented so today we're on a mission to
make sure that others have the
information that Yardley and her friends
didn't we have three main goals give all
of us a language for talking about a
subject that's quite awkward and
uncomfortable to discuss empower a whole
front front line namely friends to help
and in the process improve all of our
abilities who love better to do this
it's always important to start by
illuminating the unhealthy signs that we
frequently miss and our work really
focuses on creating content to start
conversations with young people as you'd
expect most of our contents pretty
serious given the subject at hand but
today I'm going to use one of our more
lighthearted yet still thought-provoking
pieces the couplets to illuminate five
markers of unhealthy love the first is
intensity I haven't seen you in a couple
days I've missed you I've missed you too
I haven't seen you in five minutes it
feels like a lifetime what have you been
doing without me for five whole minutes
it's been three minutes anybody
recognize that I don't know I do abusive
relationships don't start out abuse if
they start out exciting and exhilarating
there's an intensity of affection and
emotion a rush it feels really good you
feel so lucky like you've hit the
jackpot
but in unhealthy love these feelings
shift over time from exciting to
overwhelming and maybe a little bit
suffocating you feel it in your gut
maybe it's when your new boyfriend or
girlfriend says I love you faster than
you were ready for or start showing up
everywhere texting and calling a lot
maybe they're impatient when you're slow
to respond even though they know you had
other things going on that day it's
important to remember that it's not how
our relationship starts that matters
it's how it evolves it's important in
the early days of an
your relationship to pay attention to
how you're feeling are you comfortable
with the pace of intimacy do you feel
like you have space and room to breathe
it's also really important to start
practicing using your voice to talk
about your own needs are your requests
respected a second marker is isolation I
wanna hang out later me and my boyfriend
always have Monday fun day oh I want to
hang out later me and my boyfriend
always have Monday fun day tomorrow
it's our Tuesday snooze day Wednesday no
friends day if you ask me isolation is
one of the most frequently missed and
misunderstood signs of unhealthy love
why well because every new relationship
starts out with this intense desire to
spend time together it's easy to miss
when something shifts isolation creeps
in when your new boyfriend or girlfriend
starts pulling you away from your
friends and family your support system
and tethering you more tightly to them
they might say things like why do you
hang out with them they're such losers
about your best friends or they want us
to break up they're totally against us
about your family isolation is about
sowing seeds of doubt about everyone
from your pre relationship life healthy
love includes independence to people who
love spending time together but who stay
connected to the people and activities
they cared about before well at first
you might spend every waking minute
together over time maintaining
independence is key you do this by
making plans with friends and sticking
to them and encouraging your partner to
do the same a third marker of unhealthy
love is extreme jealousy what are you so
happy about she's just started following
me on Instagram what are you so nervous
about she she's just started following
me like everywhere as the honeymoon
period begins to fade extreme jealousy
can creep in your partner might become
more demanding needing to know where you
are and who you're with all the time or
they might start following you
everywhere online and off extreme
jealousy also brings
possessiveness and mistrust frequent
accusations of flirting with other
people or cheating and refusal to listen
to you when you tell them they have
nothing to worry about and that you only
love them
jealousy is a part of any human
relationship but extreme jealousy is
different there's a threatening
desperate and angry edge to it love
shouldn't feel like this
a fourth marker is belittling wanna hang
out I got a study you'll get an A anyway
a four amazing wanna hang out I got a
study you'll get an F anyway effort
effort
stupid yeah hmm an unhealthy love words
are used as weapons conversations that
used to be fun and light-hearted turned
mean and embarrassing maybe your partner
makes fun of you in a way that hurts
or maybe they tell stories and jokes for
laughs at your expense when you try to
explain that your feelings have been
hurt they've shut you down and accuse
you of overreacting why are you so
sensitive what's your problem give me a
break you're silenced by these words it
seems pretty obvious but your partner
should have your back their words should
build you up not break you down they
should keep your secrets and be loyal
they should make you feel more confident
not less
finally a fifth marker volatility I'd be
sad if we broke up I'd be sad too I'd be
so depressed if we ever broke up I
turned myself off this step I would
don't try to stop me
frequent breakups and makeups high highs
and low lows as tension Rises so does
volatility tearful frustrated fights
followed by emotional makeups hateful
and hurtful comments like you're
worthless I'm not even sure why I'm with
you followed quickly by apologies and
promises it will never happen again by
this point you've been so conditioned to
this relationship rollercoaster that you
may not realize how unhealthy and maybe
even dangerous your relationship has
become it can be really hard to see when
unhealthy love turns towards
use but it's fair to say that the more
of these markers your relationship might
have the more unhealthy and maybe
dangerous your relationship could be and
if your instinct is to break up and
leave which is advice so many of us give
our friends when there are none healthy
relationships that's not always the best
advice time of breakup can be a real
trigger for violence if you fear you
might be headed towards abuse or in
abuse you need to consult with experts
to get the advice on how to leave safely
but it's not just about romantic
relationships and it's not just about
violence understanding the signs of
unhealthy love can help you audit and
understand nearly every relationship in
your life for the first time you might
understand why you're disappointed in a
friendship or why every interaction with
a certain family member leaves you
discouraged and anxious
you might even begin to see how your own
intensity and jealousy is causing
problems with colleagues at work
understanding is the first step to
improving and while you can't make every
unhealthy relationship healthy some
you're gonna have to leave behind you
can do your part every day to do
relationships better and here's the
exciting news it's actually not rocket
science
open communication mutual respect
kindness patience we can practice these
things every day and we'll practice will
definitely make you better I have to
promise you it's also not gonna make you
perfect I do this for a living everyday
I think and talk about healthy
relationships and still I do unhealthy
things just the other day as I was
trying to shuttle my four kids out the
door and it's quarreling squabbling and
complaints about breakfast I completely
lost it with an intentionally angry edge
I screamed everybody just shut up and do
what I say you are the worst I'm gonna
take away screen time and dessert and
anything else you could possibly ever
enjoy in life
anybody been there volatility belittling
my oldest son turned around and looked
at me and said mom that's not love for a
minute I really wanted to kill him for
calling me out trust me but then I
gathered myself and I thought you know
what I'm actually proud I'm proud that
he has a language to make me pause I
want all of my kids to understand what
the bar should be for how they're
treated and to have a language and a
voice to use when that bar is not met
versus just accepting it for true too
long we've create we've treated
relationships as a soft topic when
relationship skills are one of the most
important and hard to build things in
life not only can understanding
unhealthy signs help you avoid the
rabbit hole that leads to unhealthy love
but understanding and practicing the art
of being healthy can improve nearly
every aspect of your life I'm completely
convinced that while love is an instinct
and an emotion the ability to love
better is a skill we can all build and
improve on over time thank you
[Applause]